hello everybody I was curious enough to
try to look up what the actual number
sequence was so I did and it it is it's
the word and then the letters correspond
with numbers I've obviously didn't get a
lot of them because only I only got
about three but the sequence actually is
the letter spell out forgive me so the
first number is 26 okay pushed it it's
then 16 which is over here and four then
27 right dear
49 there it is
voting nine heard it - there we go 32
right here 45 then 12 and 23 and ah
it opened okay oh let's see what's in
here
wait a minute it's back in the hospital
whoa whoa whoa whoa hang on a tick wait
a minute
oh wow holy crap
inception whoa holy crap um okay all
right cool that's cool I'll get out now
ah
what the hell okay
this is like a whole nother ending man
okay this is messed up okay was like
know something I just like totally died
ah okay caught that early this might
actually be a fight or I'll die okay
this actually might extend the length of
this episode and quite a bit damn it
unless I can can't get through here ah
[ __ ] hell it's [ __ ] all right
catch on that fire extinguisher baby ah
[ __ ] hell do I not have enough do I
not have enough health is this gonna be
just completely boning me over oh here's
a sign okay there we go all right let's
see if ah yes
okay I make it oh holy crap Mike oh wow
all right Wow
it's like trying to climb back up the
bus there we go
come on everyone oh wow how am i okay
they're here okay man this is ah [ __ ]
hell get up get up get up get up and get
up get up get up our [ __ ] house save
or load
kidding me okay there we go
got it go here go here man
there we are all right oh not another
one
come on door I swear oh [ __ ] hell
[ __ ] all right again
Oh didn't save of course I didn't why
would I that would be responsible of me
all right here we go
door don't screw with me holy crap
there's like a puzzle more than anything
and I have failing at it
catch that nope or I'll miss it
completely maybe they expected me to be
in here with you no more health than
this but they didn't expect how noobish
I am Oh God
all right man what is the deal
oh boy series inception going on here
okay let me out can you only go when it
lines up with something okay am I going
what's happening stuck I'm stuck I broke
it okay let me just wait for it to get
right back up cuz there's probably only
one way to go through it yeah
don't slide down there we go red dots
all the dots
oh boy oh what the hell what the hell
and this guy this guy's madness is
really really pervasive jammed okay oh
thank you my mother used to point at
things she wanted me to destroy oh okay
well that was simple that's like this
simplest puzzle ever
that's creepy picture though ah
all right now she's pointing at your
enemy who my enemy ah that was my enemy
what was that not the no not the
innocent the enemy what whoa
oh oh oh my god oh ah oh that hurt me
[ __ ] oh I should've oh now the what
what's going on did I
I saved it a bad point okay here we go
all right huh go away no way bro
go away go away bro away bro
I shoot it it hurts me huh what happens
I do what do i do do I do
ah you seem to have a hole in your chest
so I don't let it touch me that's for
sure I shoot it it hurts me understood I
gotta get by it no I don't know I
obviously can't shoot it
oh but I go down here okay this is
different now ah I see oh whoa whoa whoa
no buddy buddy get back get back
no not today up Mount
oh boy there's gonna be a whole spear ah
ah ah how do you get an axe uh huh uh
huh uh that's me douche nozzle wow what
is shocking me something shocking miss
me ah what was that what can I get out
of here come no okay that's weird
weird
I'll make
[ __ ]
die no not today
[ __ ] the lightning come on come on
Scott Killa quickly before the lightning
kills me
whatever it is besides kill me oh I
don't have enough time
come on what the [ __ ] maybe I got I
don't want to be standing let me make an
experiment here fight jump water aah
oh [ __ ] oh oh the lightning can't get me
in the water that's the basic idea
like this acts as a lightning around or
something give me out let me out damn it
keep me bob and weave
see there was back yeah yeah yeah back
jump in
got ya okay it's about 20 seconds for a
few shots Oh in the back again oh just
in time save good
three shots maybe
yes okay you haven't even pulled your
axe yet what's going on going on buddy
huh huh huh what's up what's up it's
like are you
there it is nope ah damn it I'll let him
get me and the back
now he's gonna pull out his there it was
pretty hard to hear it in the water
nope not gonna give me okay it's like a
lightning rod of sorts that I've got ah
damn it I didn't mean to do that
there was more wrong
ah don't pull out a gun man I'll pull
out this all I'm saying don't pull that
again how much house is this [ __ ]
have Meredith oh I wasted all my battery
up I don't need it man
there's me
oh man yeah this is gonna be a whole
nother episode I really thought this was
just gonna be an addendum but no miss me
in the water
Esme douche wrongly
surprise that water is protected am I
missing something
am I missing something to this I must be
there's no way it should take this back
oh maybe I need to like get him to open
up his arms and then impale him ah like
that maybe open up open up open up ah
well [ __ ] that wasn't it but try again
open up to me
open up buddy see it's you that seemed
to stagger him something to open up to
me
open up buddy ah [ __ ] not that open
don't be that open open up to me bro
miss ah [ __ ] you didn't man he's going a
lot longer than I thought
come on open up ah Ram damn it
all right forget that I'm just gonna
keep poking him
it's gotta be something I'm missing here
this can't be right what the hell he's
on fire how the freaky fracas at
somewhere he's he burnin
what's going on what's the deal he's out
now apparently
okay those
ah no okay all right
I must be doing something wrong
oh there we go ah
got ya [ __ ] okay all right I thought it
was never gonna get out of there
oh hello oh oh that's no good
huh oh hello I am coming back to life as
a zombie what you weren't doing much to
keep me alive
holy hell alright then
okay huh
I guess that's the good ending the bad
ending was just me killing everyone
apparently in my insane stupor so
somehow I had overcome things and I
forgave myself as per the coded message
hmm
yeah it all comes back to the hospital
yeah kind of makes me want to go back
and try for the cry of fear endings but
those are probably harder to do because
they're not as simple as putting in a
code Markland Hospital yeah that's cool
though I'm glad they have I like games
that have different endings not just
like you know red blue green endings but
actual real endings it's pretty cool and
that was only two of four innings I'm
not gonna try for the the other ones but
at least at least I got this one out of
the way the secret door was right there
available to me so that's why I did that
one but the other ones are gonna have to
wait for someone else to accomplish
I guess is kind of doing a flyby reverse
flyby of what it was going into the
hospital all right and there are the
credits all right thank you guys for
watching this episode I'm uh I didn't
think I was going to do it but I just I
was so curious I had to figure it out
thanks again for everybody for watching
this is the official end of afraid of
monsters I won't be returning so thank
you everybody for watching you've
already seen these so thanks again
everybody and I will see you in the next
video bye bye